this is iPhone 7 but there is a
beautiful new refined design for iPhone
7 it starts with this new finish we call
jet black it is absolutely stunning well
the new iPhone 7 also looks beautiful in
gold and in silver and of course rose
gold the new enclosure and iPhone 7 and
iPhone 7 plus are water and dust
resistant so this is the iphone 7 camera
new 12 megapixel camera system with
optical image stabilization wider F 1.8
aperture 6 elements in the lens there's
now two 12 megapixel cameras built in
the iPhone 7 plus one as the wide angle
28 millimeter lens the same as the
iPhone 7 the other is a telephoto 56
millimeter lens the first time there's
stereo speakers Apple earpods
are the most popular headphones in the
world now with iPhone 7 and 7 plus we're
moving to connecting them over lightning
so we've also made this it's an adapter
Lightning 2 mini foe no audio adapter
and we're gonna include that in the box
with every iPhone 7 and 7 plus as well
we are so excited to show you a new
product from Apple called Apple earpods
there's no buttons there's no switching
there's no pairing there's no unparent
those things are of the past 810 fusion
is a 64-bit 4 core processor with over
3.3 billion transistors it is a rocket
ship if you're upgrading from an iPhone
success to an iPhone 7 on average you
can expect to get about two more hours
into your day on your battery life
but we're really excited to tell you
that iPhone 7 cost the same is the
iPhone 6s that it replaces just six
hundred and forty nine dollars we've
doubled all the stores capacitive
configurations so now it's 32 gigabytes
128 gigabytes a 256 gigabytes and
jetpack plaques specifically comes on
128 and 256 gig sizes iPhone 7 plus
starts at 769 it also comes in 32
gigabytes 128 gigabytes and 256
gigabytes of we call it Apple watch
series 2 and it has been completely
re-engineered the first Apple watch was
splash proof an Apple watch series 2 is
swim proof we've added a dual-core
processor that's up to 50% faster we've
added a new entirely new GPU that
delivers two times the graphics
performance we've added built-in GPS
Apple watch series 2 will be priced at
369 Apple watch Nike Plus will also be
priced at 369 thank you